[Music]
okay everybody i'm really excited today
because
this guest that's on the show is someone
i have admired for a long time now i
feel like i grew up with him
watching shameless you probably know him
from that show as lip gallagher
i am with jeremy allen white today who
plays
josh in the new film the rental jeremy
how you doing today
hey i'm doing uh i'm doing really well
thank you for the the kind words
oh yeah no problem man and you know i
threw on this movie hearing it was dave
franco's directorial debut so i was
really interested
and it was a pleasant surprise to see
you starring in it how did this role
kind of come about for you and what was
it like working with
a first-time director and dave franco
yeah um how it came about
i pretty much i just i lucked out i got
a um
i got a cold email from dave and
he just said some really nice things um
he'd seen
you don't see me in shameless and a
couple other a couple other things and
he was a fan and
and it was just a straight straight
offer kind of like if i was interested
then he'd love to have me kind of thing
and
first i looked at you know who else was
all a part of it and you know i was a
fan of dave
so you know i was excited to get it just
just from him um but he also had his
wife allison bree who i was a fan of
attached already
dan stevens attached already i'm not
sure if sheila was attached already but
i'm a fan of her as well um so i saw
that he had kind of you know
brought a really talented group of
actors together
for it already so i was excited and then
i started reading it
and yeah it was interesting i've never
done anything really in the horror genre
but i don't know i think dave and joe
swanberg who co-wrote the script with
him they kind of like grounded the genre
a little bit i guess
sure i guess what happens in the movie
just seems plausible enough
is that i think it strikes a kind of
like honest
chord of fear with anybody you know
yeah um i would think i was interested
in that and and then dave and i
got to talking and he was like you know
i want to approach it as kind of a
character study about these
relationships and then everything goes
everything goes crazy and um yeah i just
love dave and i love talking to him and
he's so smart and so kind and it just
seemed uh
anyway it seemed like a no-brainer yeah
and it's interesting you say that it was
like
feels very grounded and i totally agree
with that and i think like you're
alluding to about just
being about characters people can relate
to and they're really strong and you
have four great acting performances here
as the leads and it's interesting just
seeing you on the first scene with
meena here and the actress of sheila
bond and i wonder you see it and you're
like wow the chemistry is amazing
between you two from the start now
it's not like where you're on a long
show developing that so was it
challenging to like
get that down with an actress just in a
movie and how that kind of comes about
is there like a test chemistry thing or
how does that work we just we
lucked out i mean sheila is so so
talented and grounding as a performer i
think she kind of like sucked me right
in
um and i think we just we lucked out in
that um
there was just like an immediate ease
and and kind of
respect for one another it just made it
just made it really
really easy and then also to kind of
like continue to compliment dave a
little bit i think
you know he put us all together i think
he did all that for
for a reason um and it you know it it it
worked
he made a really like safe environment i
think he he put the right he put the
right folks in the roles and
and uh and it just worked yeah and it's
interesting too because you're saying
like the right focus on the roles and
in a good environment and i think
there's such a good rhythm touching base
with each of you guys and
in such a short amount of time getting
to know each character and i thought a
really important scene was with josh
talking on the beach with michelle about
mina and he says
i'm constantly terrified she's going to
leave me i'm wondering you see he's
someone who's insecure about dating
someone he you know feels is
better or smarter than him do you want
to speak
yeah exactly so do you feel like you can
relate to that all in your life did it
seem like something that came easy to
you in the part to kind of pick that up
yeah yeah i mean i've i've always um
you know dated out of my weight class
and i certainly
married um out of my weight class so so
i can definitely uh
i can definitely relate relate to that
yeah trying to hold on to something
really bright and shiny and you kind of
feel like you're
you're losing it yeah and i think that's
i think you're exactly right you know i
think i think
that he you know he's had a rough
go-ahead even before the movie
kind of starts and you get the sense
that his history has
not been so happy but then when you meet
him he's with this
this girl who's just beautiful and smart
just so far out of his league and you
think
oh maybe he's going to catch a break and
then of course
quite the opposite happens and uh and
it's just kind of
tragedy after tragedy yeah and and i
feel like his
you know his brother charlie here kind
of talks down to him a bit and
i wonder if you can kind of go into that
relationship a bit too as the brothers
because
it seems a lot more complicated than it
is on the surface being that
i feel like charlie thinks he's like mr
perfect and
you know josh like you're saying comes
from a little more complicated
background can you
kind of get us in the mind of josh and
maybe how he views his brother charlie
throughout this film
yeah yeah i mean i i think kind of
like the background that i kind of
worked on for them was
you know i think charlie was always a
bit of an overreceiver
um josh and underachiever but at the
same time
i think like most younger brothers and
younger siblings you know
all they really wanted their older
siblings uh acceptance
and i think that that's something that
charlie has kind of held over
josh their entire
relationship he i mean i think it just
becomes clear
in that scene kind of early in the movie
um when he's talking to when charlie's
talking to michelle
about how he feels about mina and josh's
relationship
it's all right there you know he never
he never um he never gave
his brother a chance and he doesn't
think much of him and i think
i think josh knows that and has to live
with that and that's got to be a
you know that's got to be something very
hard to exist in do you feel
in this film that josh was suspicious of
charlie and mina from the start or was
it kind of just not plausible to him in
his head that his brother would
actually go through with that you know
what i like to think
that josh was just completely ignorant
that he was you know
he just felt like he really lucked out
with mina and that was his kind of main
his main focus a little bit you know
yeah absolutely
and i wonder too because i for me
watching this film i felt like
josh and michelle were the ones the
audience can kind of feel for a little
more
and you kind of see the other two kind
of affecting them and they don't even
notice
in a sense of stuff that's going on
behind their back and it kind of starts
the wheel of
giving this murderer the schemes to kind
of take everybody
out so i was wondering all this i
thought
who i think the audience actually can
feel the most for is actually reggie
josh's dog um do you find it all that
reggie's like
a symbol of kind of like innocence in
this story or am i reaching there
because i did find it interesting he
disappeared
right after the affair actually happened
yeah no i
i agree with you it sounds like that
reggie is
is is almost the hearer
you know i think he's got a he's got a
clear conscience and
he's he might be the uh he might be the
only one
um and i also think yeah i mean i i
when i was kind of like it might sound
spooky but
but i also thought of josh kind of as
like a
kind of like an excitable dog like an
animal kind of the whole thing you know
he was like
he's so happy to be with this person and
it's like kind of happy lucky about that
and he's got this going
but then he would also kind of like turn
on a dime and get a little bit violent
and
he just seemed to me kind of um a little
animalistic and like always on uh
on the edge so i think josh um relates a
lot to uh
to rechee as well and i do think that
chunk
who played reggie maybe you know
right after allison because dave and
allison are married but
i do think that chunk who's the actor
dog that played reggie
was the second favorite performer after
all
i love that uh yeah i mean
yeah and i think i think dogs need to
get more recognition for sure in the
industry
and i'm happy you're saying that because
i felt the same way i connected to the
dog and
it was such a vital part it's funny too
because you you talk about
josh kind of having that personality
that's a little animalistic
and i wonder asking you jeremy as a
person
do you see josh as a good guy like do
you feel for him do you
kind of understand that you know maybe
yeah he did attack
taylor towards the end there but he
didn't actually kill the guy and he
was kind of being lied to the whole
movie by basically the killer and by
his brother and his girlfriend so do you
have sympathy for josh
yeah yeah i mean what he just wanted to
be better
be better for his partner uh a better
guy so pearl's always kind of
rooting for him and then uh might have
been
just i guess so so ignorant to his
surroundings i think like you know
sometimes dogs can be their attitudes
can shift so quickly depending on the
surroundings and stuff you know
yeah i wonder too do you think
when the big moment happens and it's
revealed that josh finds out that
his brother's done the ultimate betrayal
do you think if he actually found
charlie in that last scene he would have
like actually tried to kill him
uh yes
gotten hurt i don't know if it would
have ended with uh with death but i
think someone would have gotten hurt
now i owe it to my listeners to ask you
a question just related to shameless
because it's such a popular show and you
have such an awesome character arc with
lip gallagher
i was wondering if you can kind of
compare
doing a long character arc and lip and
how that you approach a character in a
show compared to you have such a short
time with josh here and
did you find that challenging just to
jump right into it yeah i mean i think
they're
they're like challenging parts but
there's also nice parts you know what i
mean like
like it's been such a gift and it's been
so kind of exciting to play one
character for 10 plus years because i've
gotten to
grow with that character and change with
that character and
we haven't gotten that far yet so i do
find my getting very sense
is sometimes what the writer he did
you know what what's that historical
um it's nice and a fit
it's all right and things go at the end
so i know what i'm working with
right after that so yeah i think i've
come up with a little bit faster but but
you could be more
sure of yourself and like you know
sometimes with playing little
because i've done it over so many years
it might be harder to commit
at times because it's it's ever evolving
and ever changing
with the world that's so big which is
the world of shameless that's going on
for so long
you know yeah absolutely and wrapping
this up jeremy
my last question is do you have any
thoughts of also
jumping behind the camera and possibly
directing any time or
um i don't i don't think anytime soon
um i you know never say never um but
i think for for the meantime i'm going
to continue uh hopefully getting the
chance to work with some really
special folks like i did on this movie
and uh i just kind of continued
learning you know yeah absolutely well
jeremy absolutely crushed it in this
movie it was a joy to watch it it's an
awesome film
uh i appreciate it yeah man and also
everyone check them out in vienna and
the phantoms on demand now also and of
course today
the rental is out both on demand and
drive in theaters is there anything else
you want to plug jeremy before you go
um no i think i think you nailed it
thank you so much steve and um
and yeah i really appreciate it was
really nice talking to you same dear
jeremy have a great day